we will promote positive education about
the nuclear family the roles of mothers
and fathers and celebrating rather than
erasing the things that make men and
women different and unique I will ask
Congress to pass a bill establishing
that the only genders recognized by the
United States government are male and
female and they are assigned at Birth
this is damaging rhetoric it's obviously
goofy coming out of the mouth of this
pumpkin head but this is dangerous the
trans population in the United States
and likely the world
possesses some of the highest suicide
rates
among any group
this is hateful this is damaging this is
harmful